a 500 detox of just like straight up
powder no this has gone too far hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today I'm going to be talking about the
infamous 500 all powder detox diet and
I'm going to be recreating said detox
with actual food for a hell of a lot
less hit up my description for my
disclaimer as well as a link to my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook and my ltk
page where you can look at what I'm
wearing this week okay so I recently had
a viral Tick Tock where I reviewed
another Creator's 500 5 day detox from a
brand called chroma Wellness not
surprisingly I was a little shook by the
whole premise of spending 500 on powders
for only five days of your life and was
left with a lot of questions so
naturally I did a deep dive so you never
ever ever will have to let's get to it
first of all do you need to spend 500 on
a detox no if you're new here welcome
but let it be super clear that you do
not need anything to detox your body if
you're breathing peeing and pooping
congratulations you are detoxing so
really all you got to do is get in that
water some Fiber a little movement that
is all that you need to get your natural
detox organs aflo in so yeah we could
just shut this BS all down right now but
that would probably upset the hardcore
detox community so let's take a closer
look at the chroma detox itself now
according to their website this reset
allegedly helps with overall slimming
and deep loading better sleep and clear
mind weight loss of course more energy
balanced adrenals increased metabolism
function and improved digestion their
elevator pitch was that the reset would
help you re-establish healthy habits
with functional Whole Foods and
beverages which is a little ironic
considering it looks like a Rolodex of
colorful packets of powder but I
detector tests determined that was a lie
they also say that they believe that
eating healthy should be pleasurable
is not adding up right here and I'm
gonna show you why so Carla has three
different five-day protocols lifestyle
lean and active their lifestyle is
allegedly their most popular which they
say will result in an average weight
loss of four pounds their lean program
is even more restrictive which I did not
think was possible but for the record
folks if you lose four pounds in five
days on this cleanse it is simply
because you're consuming very little
real food and taking like a ton of
diuretics and laxatives this is not fat
loss it is water loss and yes you will
immediately gain it all back not sure
that's a great Roi that said let's see
what we get to eat and how we can make
it a lot cheaper okay step one of the
program is to break the fast so you're
supposed to fast for like 12 to 16 hours
to stimulate fat burning I've talked a
lot about the problem with this
statement right here but yeah I guess I
naturally fast like 12 to 13 hours just
based on what normally feels good to my
body and when I feel hungry so I guess
we're already on track with that when
you wake up you are then allowed to have
their adaptogenic beauty matcha with
either water or any kind of non-dairy
unsweetened milk and the ingredients
here do actually look pretty good we got
collagen protein we got matcha we got
adaptogens lots of clear benefits here
um and what we know is that l-theanine
and egcg in the matchup plus the
adaptogenic mushrooms will help to give
you a more slow energy release compared
with the rise and fall that you would
get from something like coffee and I'm
going to say that the ginger in there is
probably to help with digestion the
problem is we have no idea how much
we're getting of any of these
ingredients it's just a proprietary
blend so it very well could all be like
window dressing in very non-clinical
dosages regardless of the claim I can
get on barbas matcha but still it's not
a detox
so for actual breakfast they give you
this packet of what they call Super
porridge which apparently you're allowed
to eat with some berries if you want
um the porridge itself based on the
ingredient list is made up of really
nutritious ingredients so almond meal
different seeds oats some plant-based
protein flax like it really is a pretty
super porridge with lots of fiber and
healthy fats in there the fiber
specifically might benefit regularity
which would probably help with their
digestion claims but seeing as weight
loss is such a strong promise with krona
I would have expected more than just
like 10 grams of protein since we do
have ample research to support a high
protein breakfast for weight loss so I'm
going to make my own protein super
porridge here which has like three times
as much protein and is way cheaper to
make step one oats
hemp high protein milk
I'm gonna let that simmer until it Cooks
through a little
and for some protein I've got some egg
whites I'm just whisking until nice and
fluffy now we're just gonna fold in
the egg whites
what does that mean he folds it in
your arm workout
I got a super ripe banana I'm gonna Mash
that in
you turn the heat off pop on a lid
and let it sit uninterrupted for like
three minutes
of super porridge I'm gonna add a little
bit of almond butter on top yum and some
fresh berries
and if you're wondering if this tastes
eggy literally just ask the thousands of
people who have made it for my blog and
my cookbook it literally tastes like a
cloud super high in protein we got lots
of healthy fats we've got lots of fiber
it is one of my all-time favorite meals
[Music]
brutal
Santa Buddies For Life right
rough day out there perfect day for some
porridge so their next step is hydration
so they have this cranberry hydration
Elixir as they call it
um which you're allowed to sip
throughout the day as needed or
post-workout so this is like an
electrolyte drink it's made with coconut
water cranberry ginger and cayenne I'm
assuming the cranberry is just to add
some flavor and vitamin C
um the coconut water adds a little bit
of electrolytes like magnesium and
potassium for a hydration system this
literally offers nowhere near the
clinical dosages for electrolytes the
only reason that I can see for the
addition of the ginger and the Cayenne
is to make you poop which I mean I guess
is how they sell it as a detox but yeah
I'm gonna take a pass at that since I
literally got the same amount of
magnesium and even more potassium just
from the banana that I add added to my
oats in a lot of cases water is more
than enough
moving on is the Boost I love the names
I really do um so we get a smoothie and
there's a few different flavors to
choose from there's also so little
sodium in this day so far like even with
the addition of the electrolyte powder
you might look slightly less puffy but
all of that would immediately return to
normal the moment you ate real food and
you'd also feel like complete so let's
make an actual chocolate banana smoothie
that doesn't suck top secret chocolate
protein powder
milk
I'm using the higher protein milk which
I love a real banana that's not just
like dehydrated banana powder a little
bit of peanut butter
and to add some extra micronutrients and
fiber I've got some ran bits of cooked
broccoli here
oh yeah baby
um
that is so good
way more protein plus fiber and healthy
fats and a hell of a lot cheaper to make
cheers
finally it's lunch time and you think at
this point you'd get to like chew
something but no you literally get
powdered broth just powder and not even
the good stuff
oh I blew it but like honestly for
something worth 500 you are seriously
eating like
post-apocalyptic End of the World style
I do not understand this anyway I assume
the point of this is to a keep calories
as low as possible seeing as there's
only 80 calories in this lunch and B to
heal the gut with the bone broth base
now in short I'm actually a big fan of
bone broth I love it mainly because I
think it's a really good high protein
base for soup but we also do have some
early lab studies suggesting that the
unique amino acids in bone broth like
collagen gelatin Glycine and glutamine
may help to strengthen the gut barrier
and to soothe gut inflammation but the
funny thing about this particular
product is that I actually see a lot of
high FODMAP ingredients in this base so
like onion garlic chives which probably
make it taste a lot better but may also
exacerbate IBS symptoms like bloating
and gas honestly at this point the whole
powdered food thing is kind of like
freaking me out what freaking out
so let's upgrade this like a million
fold step one bone broth
and then literally whatever vegetables I
have in the fridge I got some bell
peppers some snap peas and some already
roasted carrots
all right add in some chicken
and some chickpea noodles that I've
pre-cooked the thing that anyone would
try to sell you powdered broth over this
is mind-blowing but we have way more
nutrition going on we have all the
benefits of the bone broth but we also
have benefits from all the veg the fiber
rich noodles and the chicken oh and I
added in some sourdough because
the detox
if you can boil water and put it into
powder you can also definitely do this
okay so after lunch it's time for the
fuel phase where basically you get
Cronus version of ag1 which is called
their super green Elixir not unlike ag1
it's basically like a laundry list
proprietary blend of everything
expensive vegetable and extract Under
the Sun so I do see some adaptogens I
see some digestive enzymes some
probiotics green tea aloe vera Etc which
are all really great and possibly are
very helpful but I also see a ton of
fodmaps here which I just do not get
apple fiber cauliflower broccoli stem
kale artichoke Leaf like these are some
of the highest FODMAP sources this could
be like Napalm for your bowels if you
have IBS and listen I have no qualms
with greens powders I actually think
that they're a simple source of
micronutrients if you're like on the go
or maybe you just don't get a lot of
those nutrients in they're literally a
flavored powdered multivitamin which I
love but they're not a substitute for
real vegetables like you literally have
less than a gram of fiber per serving
and I assume there's a need to get more
micronutrients in this diet because
there is so little actual nutrition in
this day but in my case with all the
meal tweaks that I've made I'd say it's
like completely obsolete so we can move
on next is their snack time which sadly
is also not chewable it's another latte
but this one actually does sound
delicious so we got adaptogenic
mushrooms and ashwagandha which we do
have research to support its use for
anxiety blood sugar regulation and
fitness just to name a few benefits so I
am totally into incorporating something
like this into my afternoon ritual but
again this is not a detox like I'm
pretty sure in the context of this day
this is just a low calorie distraction
from your actual hunger and since I've
been eating all day again I can probably
pass on said snack now the next phase is
the energy protein snack not to be
confused with the other snack which was
just a latte so this is their oh my God
cookie butter but it does sound like
it's the best part of this detox because
you actually get to chew something that
would be a hell of a lot better on some
bread so it's basically a combination of
different nut Butters oil hemp protein
powder and sugars it's got 110 calories
per tablespoon 4 grams of carbs and
three grams of protein again for an
alleged energy protein snack there is
neither a lot of energy nor protein in
this so I'm going to do my version that
won't cost 25 per jar and I'm gonna be a
rebel and I'm gonna put it on some
[Music]
thank you
foreign
the thought of having to eat just a
spoonful of nut butter as my only
chewable meal of the day is giving mad
Kelly Ripa Vibes and that is my first
chewable food of the but this my friends
is how you eat nut butter
the crunch Factor Protein healthy fats
fiber
definitely the best part of the day I
will say that but I'm not super hungry
right now so I'm going to save this for
my final meal so dinner is again
another sachet of broth yay so this time
we are allowed to add a little bit of
veggies or protein which I already took
the liberty of doing in round one so I'm
just gonna finish off the batch that I
made earlier and call it a boring food
day
um at least my snack is interesting so I
can enjoy that you guys always hear me
say that varieties of spice of life and
it's so important that we're getting a
variety of different foods in our diet
not just for micronutrient diversity but
also for gut microbiome diversity that
says nobody has to make a whole
different meal every single day every
day of the week I don't I love leftovers
why would I cook twice or three times
when I can cook once and just get the
job done healthy eating shouldn't be
complicated and it definitely doesn't
need to be an exorbitant amount of work
or cost a lot of money so variety can
also look like choosing carrots and
broccoli on one week and then having
peas and parsnips the next it's all
about the bigger picture and the long
game not the minutia of every single
meal or every single day still just as
good as it was at lunch
all right step 529 after dinner so post
dinner you get a sachet of their
magnesium supplement which is supposed
to help calm the Mind soothe the muscles
and support the digestive system so I
can see from their information that they
use a magnesium blend which is actually
pretty smart since different forms of
magnesium have different uses in the
body so the citrate is a laxative so I
assume that again supports their detox
Mo the gluconate is sometimes used for
sleep but really the chelated version
glycinate is much better in my opinion
and the Magnesium acetyl tarnate is
mostly study for heart health but it may
have some potential for stress TBD
really the problem is just that based on
the total magnesium blend it's not
nearly enough for a clinical dosage like
you're way better off just buying a
magnesium supplement from your drugstore
in the specific form that you need and
just taking that especially since the
inulin root in this blend might again
egg bloating and gas like I just don't
get that piece but anyways that's what I
do I take magnesium visclicity because I
don't need a laxative every night I just
really want to sleep better and this
actually helps me if you're wondering
when this hellish day can end
congratulations we are finally here the
last stage is back to fasting
naturally so at the end of the day
you're supposed to have this perfect
fast Ginger turmeric detox and calming
tea to allegedly curb the urge to late
night snack naturally it's literally
just Ginger turmeric Licorice and some
other herbs and spices and yes Ginger
does have some Pro kinetic properties
meaning that it can kind of help to
support normal bowel motility and
function but again if this tea does
anything to help you detox it's just by
helping you drink more water which makes
you pee which as we established is your
body's way of detoxing naturally it's
also again a distraction from the fact
that you have eaten so very little for
five days so yeah a non-caffeinated tea
is a great way to end the day but it's
not a detox so to summarize it blows my
mind how much people pay for so little
actual food like this detox provides 850
calories a day like you're spending a
hundred dollars for less than a thousand
calories of food let that sink in so
yeah the reason why you might look
slimmer or actually see a temporary drop
on the scale is because you're starving
and you've just taken a ton of laxatives
and diuretic supplements all day if
you're really desperate to drop water
weight like this you might as well just
take an over-the-counter laxative for
twenty dollars and like spend your days
on the toilet not that I'm recommending
people ever do that but it would
literally do the same thing so folks
please
please be wary of these overpriced
overhyped detox programs with beautiful
marketing like it is beautiful but it's
a waste of money at best and it's
dangerous at worst definitely not Abby
approved save your money and go buy my
cookbook
Shameless plug I don't
know about that I have for you guys
today
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on what you'd like to see me do next
subscribe to the channel don't forget to
hit up my description for my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]